[Music]
drunk
hello hello
[Music]
nope you're so bad you look like
uh the Easter version of the Unabomber
no I look like uh the grape and Fruit of
the Loom who was played by David Alan
Greer yep but also for what I said
though so I look like David I am like
David Alan Grier David anger is great
thank you no I'm not saying what you
were saying is that I'm like him and you
should open that before we started
recording is is the deal the deal is
that wouldn't have made it that much of
a noise and now you calling it out makes
it all different no you can open it in
like 10 minutes
but you opened it literally 10 seconds
after that I see it's not good I see
it's not good to do
um so you were sick now you're not
you're a little bit still I I'm not I
don't yeah I'm like you know how it is
at the end of a cold where you're just
like when is it gonna totally end yeah
that's where I'm at I guess that's where
I am too I mean copying me no what
happened I didn't think I was sick okay
oh okay then that's not where you're at
I convinced myself I'm not sick until
I'm getting better and then I'm like
maybe I was sick uh well I I wish I
could have done that I was so messed up
though it wasn't coveted it was not
covered I could not
swallow oh that's the worst enduring
excruciating pain ah did you get it
can't get a shot for that I've had shots
in the past cortisone but I did not
because I didn't want to go to the
doctor I was like
does that help the cortisone shots oh
yeah well then why didn't you just get
one because I have to go to the doctor
it would be so much better though
because honestly I don't think he would
have given me one because it was only a
sore throat I didn't have a fever I
didn't have an infection it was just it
was or I didn't have a bacterial
infection okay that's the reason he gave
he gave it to me that one time in my
rarest Maximus okay is because I was
very sick in a number of ways and I
needed I had a massive fever and I
needed the swelling in my throat to go
down so I could continue to live rarest
Maximus yeah so you could continue to
live okay cool yeah well so they were
like pulled on your pants I need to
inject this into your urius Maximus and
I was like I didn't say that but I just
met you no right not no that's something
like that a 68 year old would say okay
well does a 68 year old
honestly a 68 year old in 1980 would say
it there's a six does a 68 year old have
this
uh no George Michael died so yeah he
wouldn't be 68. he might what if he was
actually going to be 68 if he was still
alive yeah then I would have been great
check it out does it do this a dolphin
does it does it do this this because I
don't think it does so
yeah I'm I so I was in therapy today and
my and I was like man I just feel down
and like you know not like happy and I
don't know what it is I'm just like I
told my wife like I told Kristen I was
like just so you know I'm gonna not
gonna do I'm gonna leave my face how
it's gonna be I'm not gonna do extra
like smiling and stuff if I don't want
to smile I'm not gonna smile so if you
say something I might think it's cool
but I'm not gonna smile extra because of
it just to let you know that I think
it's cool my face is gonna do what it's
gonna do it's deeper and how'd that go
no and so I told my therapist and she's
like you're just you sound like rat your
throat throat is raspy and I was like
yeah a little bit she's like are you
just sick and I was like I don't know
and at the end of the therapy she helped
me figure out that I was just sick and
that's why you're feeling like but how
dumb is that like nah I'm not gonna do
it like that that's that's why you were
acting that way she's saying no no no no
no no no she was just like you don't
feel happy oh because you're just sick
and I was like yeah maybe you're right
by the end of it how dumb is that that
I'm that dumb that I need therapy to
figure out if I have a cold yeah that's
weird that's like going to a GP to
figure out if you need to talk
about your mother you know yeah yeah
exactly yeah the opposite so yeah so
that's where I'm at right now I need
therapy now as a medical doctor for like
physical stuff so yeah yeah that's
really mixed up
um but it's cool and I'm still really
smart you have to admit I I don't I I
don't uh I don't think you are smart
yeah you do I don't think that yeah you
do let me let you do let me be honest
with you okay I don't think that you're
not being honest with me I think I'm
smart for those who are watching and
can't see it he's actually lifting up
one leg when he does it two both legs
like this
how about this
whoa
so
dumb well Calvin likes it dude uh he's
three dude
we're having a good time dude having a
good time no having a good thank you
we're not coming to Hollywood so look
people really like this podcast I'm
gonna be honest with you I'm gonna be
honest with you too okay people really
like this podcast they they come to my
shows and they say how much they like it
and they say don't stop doing it and I
you know I guess we're not but like uh
so we're going to keep doing the podcast
but also uh leave uh leave a what do you
call a comment leave a comment and
subscribe and then also like tell your
friend about it if you like the podcast
let's get it going dude I'm telling you
right now if we're sitting at these
views for the for 10 years We're not
gonna be doing it so you're saying what
about the comment leave it leave a
comment how the algorithm go oh yeah
leave a comment leave a comment yeah
it's all right but um so yeah so that's
that's that I'll be in Austin Midland uh
I'll be in Minneapolis Minneapolis
shooting my special that you're gonna
direct and I will be in Milwaukee go to
chrislea.com and also I will be in Ohio
chrisley.com uh if you want to come see
me on Torah uh if you have a question
click the link on the description below
or go to watch lifeline.com and if you
want one-on-one sessions uh for advices
with Matt here one on one with Matt
Dalia uh just go to madelia.com it's not
therapy but Matt has advises for you and
you can also get a great Lifeline merch
at lifelinemerge.com so yeah so that's
it I haven't seen you in a bit or what
yeah no no I saw you for Calvin's
birthday oh right and then you got sick
you probably got sick from coming down
[Music]
falling why did you why'd you invite me
do you think you got sick from that no I
hadn't thought about it but if you think
you did though now no oh maybe it's
possible oh yeah well I I think maybe
you did I don't like when people are
like oh I I think I know where I got
sick unless someone they were around was
sick and like coughing all over them mom
mom mama's sick oh she came anyway she's
bad oh oh why you gotta do me like that
Mom no it wasn't that she was she was
pretty much over it but I still think
she probably had it I think she was
doing what I was doing saying like I'm
not sick I'm not sick I got that from
Mom [__] man thank God yes you need to
go to therapy again uh I think uh when
people you know Mama's watches she's
like no they always blame everything on
me we're not we're making a joke yeah no
I blame everything on on Chris not you
Mom yeah okay well it's all good I love
you mommy weird Mommy I love you you
feel weird
you know when you get sick you laugh all
weird yeah dude I left like this oh
oh that's great look at drowning
Englishman yeah so messed up uh
anyway dude let's talk about Pedro uh
Pascal oh okay he's cool he's very cool
and that's it moving on but people
aren't moving right they're not moving
him up then they're not moving on
Because the Internet is so obsessed
people are so obsessed with uh Pedro
Pascal that a viral v a video went viral
of him
just because he got Starbucks
oh that sounds interesting what did he
do he got first of all it's my drink
that I get he got it and everyone's like
this is the Pedro Pascal that you that
you can get which is four shots over ice
which is what I get dude so he stole it
from me so I'm sexy okay but what is the
deal with Pedro Pascal well who cares
that's my point he's great he's cool but
people are going nuts over him because
he wore like a shirt with no collar no
it's because he's on the biggest show
that there is right now right yeah but
also the Mandalorian yeah he's good he's
a huge star
and he's having that moment now he's
like he's like in his 50s okay but what
about no he's not 48 but what about
Chris Pratt who is a big star and it's
not like that I know why white no what
he is like uh people I don't even know
if this is true but people think of him
as like someone who's staunched the
right wing that's why dude I that's all
I ever hear about him anymore yeah
you're right you have to be a bit but
the media say what you want about the
media it's like that is
filled with like fall in line left yeah
yeah well for sure so they're not going
to care about Chris Pratt they're going
to care about Pedro Pascal because
sexiness Latino because right not white
never said anything about anything but
equality B is not white and uh
yeah he also is really really funny and
Charming no he is a great actor I'm not
but it's beyond that it's beyond that I
don't even know that because you're
telling me that you brought him up I
said I love him and you said he's cool
and I said he's cool and then you said
we're done talking about it because it
sounds like you have something going on
no if you open your phone you can't and
you start scrolling you cannot go three
minutes without seeing something about
Peter Pasco yeah you can't okay so do
you know that or not I think I do know
that there we go then you do know that
yeah so then I'm bringing it out of you
I'm like a therapist so he's the guy
who's having a minute right now yeah
okay cool good for him but more so his
minute is
jam-packed the seconds
oh not just 60 huh no dude he's got like
so many seconds on top of each other
that equal this one minute so he's
having like a 15 minutes a full-blown
minute no but it's not longer because it
might not who knows how long it's going
to last so now but it's a full-blown
hardcore Flamin Hot Minute you're
bending space time Pedro Pedro Pascal is
betting space spending space time yes
okay yeah well that sounds newsworthy to
me full-blown hardcore flaming hot
minute that's a good title I gotta say
though ever since he was in Game of
Thrones I really
I really like him and I really yeah I
think he's like a really handsome yeah
he's Charming yeah is a hundred percent
and not taken dude if it was me in that
position I'd be like guys all right so
what's he doing he is just being like
yeah because he's like oh he just did oh
I see I see I see I see yeah he got a
four here's the thing I'm bitter because
the Dude took my drink and took it went
public with my drink and now my drink it
doesn't even feel like my drink anymore
dude I think I think that his drink has
more shots two more shots in it right
but people are but it's a quad shot with
two extra shots so people are saying
quad shot so now I can't say quad shot
without thinking about it do you both
know about Pedro Pascal's story because
it's everywhere that's my point what I
haven't seen anything about Pedro Pascal
going to Starbucks what are you guys
talking also why does anyone care about
don't be sneakily saying that Pedro
Pascal drinks more hardcore coffee than
I he did say that yeah I think it's
actually more basically
that you're a total [__] he was
sneakily being like I think it's
actually more and I wasn't even gonna
address that that was okay fine dude I'm
getting seven from now seven shots in
one cup just gonna be so wired and
yelling all the time you guys know about
Pedro Pascal be outside coffee
dude he's like he's got so many seconds
back to this minute it's crazy right oh
wow Game of Thrones [__] narcos
[__] the other one [__] the zombie
one Jesus Christ Patriot Pascal's insane
security comes
just carts your ass away what you'd only
pay for the skull
with the [__] same thing with
brooker's Bradley Chris press White
[Laughter]
Chris Pratt is uh storage Republicans
not even that true maybe ask my brother
basically just a typical crazy person at
a coffee yeah oh [__] uh yeah but Chris
Pratt also because you brought him up
sticking with that example is so boring
nah Chris Pratt wait what do you mean oh
like as a person out and about yeah he
doesn't really do stuff like but he's
not but he's a good act I think he's a
great I love his acting all right well I
think he's funny he's starting to sound
like you own you like every actor who
what actor do you not like oh my god
dude
name somebody name somebody
uh Pedro Pascal yeah Goldblum he oh
enough already dude yeah I agree about
that enough dude with his purple suits
okay yeah yeah who else like he's in
Kings of Comedy name one what about
Laura Dern she's great you love
everybody okay that's another one uh
okay
um Viola Davis oh she's amazing okay see
what I'm talking about all right we'll
keep going please I I'll try somebody
who's less considered good yeah really
Jesus guy's like Meryl's free uh uh Seth
Green
he's nice a nice guy
I like say something bad about a nice
person so I don't know he's messing up
the okay uh what about
oh look Pedro pascos uh Starbucks order
interesting I'm gonna watch that when I
get home
um
uh who else do we like uh uh Alec
Baldwin
it's funny all right dude like can I
just all right you know it's like
everybody Salma Hayek
Ed Norton Ed Norton he's good he's good
Daniel Craig I love him wow dude okay
this is I didn't even realize this about
you but you like every I didn't realize
about me either yeah you like everything
I thought I don't like any actors yeah
but truth comes out wait hold on there's
got to be some that I don't like uh yeah
but Jamie Lee Curtis like uh that's
pretty good
all right well good luck everybody
Peter Dinklage
I think he gets he's really good but he
gets extra [__] because he's you know
oh you only like the ones with the extra
you know what else come on uh
uh who else you guys come on uh
uh Brad Pitt Brad Pitt I mean he's
handsome so that's all you're gonna say
about him [__] [__] man I think all
these guys are good all right never mind
yeah yeah you like every actor he's good
all right I like a lot of actors
um Jeremy Renner
he's good I like him you love running
well you know I love General but I
remember even long ago you talk about
how good he was in the town
yeah he's good dude and that always
bothered me that you said that why
because it was like you're gonna talk
about the town and you're like you're
gonna talk about a guy with like a
smaller role in it yeah
that is annoying but Jeremy Renner that
was what I think that was because that
was when I first saw him it's like when
someone's like you know he really steals
the show though but I didn't say that
yeah but no no I would never say Jim
render steals the show you said but you
basically had the sentiment of someone
who's like yeah I know there's that big
movie that everyone loves no you know
who really stole the show dude I don't
know that's basically what you did I
don't do that maybe not but it's
essentially the thing you did you know
the number one that doing that thing you
did you know what the the one thing that
quit by the way so many people in the
comments said that they knew exactly
dude I told you everybody knows I quit
from that thing you do so look uh you
know who stole the show is uh who's that
actor Christopher something in American
Beauty
Christopher Christopher isn't his name
Christopher I don't know what role does
he play the neighbor oh Chris Cooper
Chris Cooper his whole name sounds like
Christopher yeah his name is Chris he
stole the show in America video okay
let's go to
um let's go to a thing dude we got off
on that yeah we got going on yeah Pedro
Pascal so it's the next one hey Matt and
Chris it's Dan from Amsterdam uh love
you guys love the podcast love all your
content
um but yeah so what I need some advice
on is apparently my fiance looks like my
mom
um oh so uh wow I gotta showed a picture
to my cousin and he's like oh she looks
like your mom I was like no she doesn't
thought nothing of it whatever
uh-oh recently though
came to me or said something like I had
to look at the picture a little bit
harder I saw on Facebook because I
couldn't tell the difference between
your mom and uh your fiance
and that obviously messed with me come
on way more than my cousin did nice
house
um so yeah I don't know how do I handle
this situation like what do I say to
someone that comes to me and says that
uh am I sick for
for I mean loving this this woman
um obviously I'm not gonna leave her I
love her to death she's my soulmate but
leave your mom I don't really know how
to handle this yeah get a new mom I
think I guess so any advice would be
great thanks guys you need a new mom
also we should have wrote him back and
asked for pictures tell those people
he's bad Chris Walker's bad yeah you're
bad dude how could you not ask the dude
for pictures well uh because
I mean because then I need to do consent
yeah it takes he didn't think about the
consenting he just didn't do it takes a
lot more time thought about doing it and
thought I don't want to do all the work
yeah so so here's what the advice is
tell those people
stop looking like ask ask no no the
people who comment on it oh right ask
the people if they've ever heard of
humans and the brains yeah yeah yeah
true because if if they've heard of
humans and the braids that they have
they wouldn't actually ask that question
because it is a very common thing
um hello Sigmund Freud no don't do that
knock but it's honestly why you've
always dated girls that look like Dad
yeah right no but you always
you you do you look for someone that has
the qualities the good qualities come on
and sometimes you're bad the bad ones
typically
not typically even but it is a very
common thing that both men and women do
they seek out the
opposite sex parents yep like a lot of
women I know
even if they like purport to hate the
qualities that they that they're sort of
taking on they date men and end up with
men who are just like their dads
sometimes even look like them and the
truth is men do that too uh hello knock
knock
we're in traffic also to say knock knock
and also do the knock knock is
absolutely redundant yeah
um but yeah and and then women like
their their dad right that's what they
say like oh like I just said you were
talking about did you say that yeah yeah
okay cool yeah that's why the sexiest
thing you could say to a woman is hey if
you make a mess you better clean it up
that's why every girl is from Long
Island and
and the daughter of an abusive dad
haha
interesting but they can't help but they
go like this
I I do
[Laughter]
after yourself
I have to laugh like that now because
I'm sick that's so dumb dude it sucks
and and then and then when they bring it
when the dad brings them down an aisle
and she's supposed somebody says after
yourself and she doesn't like it and
then the guy goes I do and then
afterwards the ceremony you should drop
something he says
so secured us to get to that so yeah man
it's not about
the people who are dragged up in this
did you just rewind your yeah I'm trying
not to say bad words oh you were yeah
you can say bad words now okay for
[__] sake wow the [__] up people in
this situation but are that's right
Knock knock hello Sigmund Freud beep
beep knock knock knock knock
uh are the people who who say something
about it I'm like oh your fiance really
looks like your mom like what a dick
thing you say yeah because now when
you're having sex with your fiance
you're gonna be thinking about your mom
yeah no one wants that you can just
knock on their head and be like Sigmund
Freud yeah exactly knock on their skull
and say that's what you should do
wow your fancy looks a lot like your
mommy look at this
hello Sigmund Freud you ever heard of
him yeah is anybody knowing that uh is
anybody I look at Pedro Pascal over here
oh no dude it's the Pedro Pascal yeah
they already named it that well he added
a shot didn't even ask for it but knows
me well also dude what's up with the no
when the ice melts by the time the post
mice gets here oh dude oh
the guy from Police Academy so yeah it's
on them the people that are calling it
out verbally to you
a preacher are to you
guys want me to go ahead go ahead no the
people
the people who are calling it out to you
okay because I knew I knew I saw it all
right you did it good I just I was doing
it good yeah no but come on yeah okay
shut up okay uh they're the people who
have the problem you're not doing
anything wrong uh yeah I'm sure your
mom's noticed and that's maybe a little
bit weird for her but man Mom this is
Stacy she's just like this
wow well they turned into what scanners
Tom Cruise
all right cool uh all right we can do
the next one yeah
hey guys it's me pause she got that
throat piece dude yeah everyone everyone
has eyes what everyone has eyes so we
see it so you don't need to say anything
you don't need to pause it no but I'm
saying I I should get a throat piece
okay right I don't I don't know but I
did know you were gonna somehow make it
about you now let's start over give her
the okay well that's why I said pause
that because I want to talk over there's
a bad reason to pause right she has a
good throat piece oh good throat piece
what is it I don't know what it is all
you said was that it was a throwback
honestly having a throw piece is [__]
awesome no matter what it doesn't matter
what it is I'm being dead serious see
you later man
what if it was uh
big guy just like slamming a giant penis
of his into a like a big tree
so you're not right for this company
um yeah the tree is like falling because
his dick is so heavy and Powerful you
know so here's what I'd like uh I don't
know you want your take on it picture
like a guy his penis he's holding it
he's swinging it into a tree but the
here's the thing it's so big and it's so
mighty and what do you do with that what
would you do with that
yeah come back with something ill wow
that's really good yeah okay that's cool
I could see it maybe a different size
um
yeah uh okay so let's look at the what
the what the throat piece lady wants to
say
hey guys it's me Jamie again from
Calgary Alberta I just wanted to give
you guys a little bit of an update first
so I did take your advice and sent my ex
that podcast episode wow and he by the
way this is the ashes
the the ex-boyfriend left and said yeah
go ahead his uh his father's Ash is at
her house when they broke up yeah and uh
he took her
his PS5 and left the ashes behind and uh
yeah okay and was like mail them yes
yeah and I was like mail them I don't
want to come get them yeah
other stuff like he was saying like can
you respect my father's ashes by putting
him like on the mantle oh yeah wow wow
wow that's right all sorts of crazy [__]
going on with this one all right good
job Anthony thanks Anthony not Marco
suddenly just wanted his dad back
immediately so wow he is no longer with
me uh you guys completely solved that
issue for me thank you so much
um did it second thing I want to say is
Matt I completely agree with you we are
meant to be together how can we deny our
compatible hairlines slide into my DMs
this is me shooting my shot my DMs are
open for you in public third thing I
want to say is this is a follow-up
question
um and it's completely unrelated to the
whole ashes thing uh but I have a an
autoimmune disease called ulcerative
colitis no it's very similar to Crohn's
disease no no yeah I know it yeah um I I
had to get my large intestine removed
when I was 13. sorry to hear it um and
it is a big factor in my life
um is that something as far as dating
goes is that something that would make
you apprehensive to date someone if they
have pre-existing medical conditions
that do impact their life and may impact
their life even more down the road is
that something that you would kind of be
cautious of dating someone or would that
not be an issue for you at all I'm just
curious
um because I just tell people when I'm
going on dates I just tell people that's
right because
if you can't deal with it then that's
not going to work
I'm just curious to know what it's like
I don't the other end thank you guys
again so much Matt can't wait to hear
from you and my DMs
um you know no she doesn't she made that
clear she likes me yeah I I
yeah I actually was thinking about this
the other day because they someone
called in on Golden hour and did the
same uh asked this ass something uh
somebody had something not that but they
were like when do I tell oh a kid it was
a kid that STD and um and a kid had an
STD no I'm just kidding oh that's the
STD you get oh oh yes it's a hilarious
joke I would have gone it if I wasn't a
little bit sick yeah okay that's okay
yeah and you would have laughed regular
not that way because you don't laugh
that regularly right yeah exactly so
anyway
um yeah the uh you know well something
like that I think you don't have to
bring up first date no no but that's
also not the question the question is
yeah I know the met we as men I know the
question well go ahead and answer it I'm
saying first of all my thing would we
and then okay so then what is she I
would not I would not I would let love
lead yeah if you I mean I actually think
it's like it's sort of the inverse of
a red flag like like emotional
or psychological damage is much more
concerning than some kind of like
internal physical damage oh yeah like
and that I don't if I really loved
someone fell in love with especially if
I just like met someone fell in love
with them and I found out they had all
sort of colitis I would not
oh whoa whoa whoa not even for a second
yeah exactly not even for a second you
would correct me if I'm wrong but you'd
be like okay well what do we have to do
to make it to where you're comfortable
and everything is okay and like we take
care of you yeah make me a part of
making your life better yeah 100
whatever I can do I would too and and a
lot of people are like that I think yeah
I think most any guy who's like it
doesn't matter how much I like a girl if
she had ulcerative colitis she's gone
well hey that guy is
a [__] loser right and your peace
what is that you piece oh piece of [__]
yeah yeah that's horrible yeah loser
piece of [__] and also like what are you
like that's like an actual psychopath
move because there's like no feelings
yeah yeah of actual feelings of love
it's just like this completely
superficial dumb thing all sort of
colitis I'm not too clear on what it is
but I know yeah she got her intestine
removed large intestine she said yeah
which means she's got to go potty way
quicker after she eats right it also
means there's way more room in there for
you know what disgusting the most
disgusting you've ever been a big old
Winky
I mean she might be for you yeah if you
got a big old what are you doing well
you don't so you shouldn't hit no I have
a big Winky
I have a big wing
all right trying to get around the
YouTube yeah no I don't I I would not
even like it like if Kristen had
something like that I wouldn't even
everything would be the same except for
I would be concerned about it I want to
help and she would be in pain more often
well everything will be the same in the
relationship oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
anyway uh well yeah my sympathy goes out
to you for having that but any guy if
you get any whiff of any guy being like
having trepidation because of that guy's
a [__] loser yes psychological damage
it's psychological [__] is way worse
usually people with physical symptoms or
physical uh ailments ailments also have
more psychological [__] up [__]
because they have to deal with them they
don't know how to but you seem a very
good uh
see I think the almost the opposite
because they have to deal with it yeah
and then they overcome it they've gotten
to this point so far and they've like
persevered you're right people go
through physical [__] at a young age it
really changes them you're right dude
grow up yeah you're right dude it
changes and I can admit when I'm wrong
oh okay but it's not even really that I
was wrong no it wasn't so stop yelling
is what I'm gonna say yeah I was just
kind of feeling it out I was as I was
talking and then you kind of helped with
that
okay well I'm glad I could be of service
to you but yeah it makes yeah yeah yeah
okay
first I can just stop talking okay
so I can just finish doing this
uh yeah it makes you
be
that much more of an appealing potential
partner because you are more likely to
have your [__] together upstairs than
your average person even so it's
actually a plus and if guys are not
think of it that way then they stupid
especially because they're not realizing
they got extra room in there for God hey
man that's so not true you know they're
mystery so not true like oh about the
doctor was like but there is an upside
have you ever heard of a large winky
um
take two of those and call me in the
morning uh yeah uh yeah okay well next
one
so bored okay I saw you in Chicago on
New Year's Eve a couple years back and I
saw you in Rockford back in the fall wow
that was hilarious as always uh I got
one for both of you guys I need uh both
sides of your input okay uh I'm 24 my
little brother's 18 and now that he's 18
he thinks you know he's the big man in
the horse sure big guy with the last
name and I gotta knock him down a few
pegs I'm still a big bro Chris
um what is something you have done wish
you would have done or would do as an
older brother to you know kind of let
Matt know where he's at and Matt what is
something that will really get under
your skin or something that Chris has
done that bothers you uh any input will
be helpful gotta remember that I he's
got to remember that I am that guy so
please guys there's not that much thanks
dude there's not that much
first of all it's a deeper on this guy
but go ahead okay it's a deeper so it
like literally just got done digging um
I I you know uh I I don't know what I
would do to I don't you know what I mean
like he's asking what I would do to like
check you yeah we're not like that yeah
we're not like I've never been like that
we did grow brothers are like that
though
we're just siblings in general not even
just brothers yeah it's weird how much
we're not like that actually yeah and
and uh and and I was pretty much always
good to you well I wouldn't that's
actually not the same thing no it's not
but I would I I think that I'm I
wouldn't go that far and one time when
we grew up you you one time when we grew
up you realized that I maybe you thought
I wasn't always good to you you weren't
that's why it really makes me think
really [__] up I mean really [__] me
up well you should have been different
then but what I what what was I doing
that wasn't good make a funny in front
of your friends no okay no making fun of
me in front of your friends uh that was
a big that was a big nice thing yeah
okay uh well that affected you that that
affected you and I know it did and I you
know so then you were bad
you're a bad brother do you like who you
are right now
mostly mostly well it could have been
because of that right yeah no it could
be the little part that I'm not it's
probably that
um yeah I I uh yeah I I so that would be
the thing making fun of you and from my
friends that you wouldn't have won a
clown his ass in front of your boys dude
make him feel like he's [__] selfies
where do we set it do it and make him
[__] cry for three days in his room
see how that goes over before you guys
all want to come over
hello oh hey come on in nine guys hey
you're fat
my brother
my little brother he's a big man in the
house yeah big man like this big man now
fat guy right I guess man you're a dick
they leave see you guys later see ya you
want to come to the to the 18 year old
I guess
life oh Lifeline is the question toward
me what could you how did I do he said
what did I do that got under your skin
Oh that that's my answer for that yeah
yeah anything else yeah but what about
you then what well my his question for
me is what should I have done to check
you a little bit more but what should he
do is what he's really saying to check
his brother right well he did ask me
that and you didn't answer because you
said why don't you do this which is
relating it to your answer which is a
good one I answered my part yeah no you
answered also my part wow two birds one
stone we did it it's not the thing where
you should be bragging about we did it
we did it we did it all right so if you
have a big Mr winky you can have sex
with her no I did good on the question
and you did good too okay and it's
called now again all right this feels so
good in here now though let's go let's
go let's go baby what's up brother yeah
hell yeah
a giant dude a [__] absolute giant
with a regular coffee cup makes Dave
Bautista look a regular sized wow dude
Dave Batiste is the biggest man I've
ever seen in my life and when you shake
his hand it's like wrestling a wall okay
oh what I want to know is why is his
head uh wrinkled as [__] bald guys
everyone says like that when they're
bald especially if they're big forget it
oh okay mine's not the raw the The Rock
though is that radio the rock is like
that too it might be a side effect of
the [__] and I'm not gonna say I
don't want to expose everyone and I
don't know David diesel like that but it
could be the ruins and I'm not I don't
mean that right again I was like yeah
right and dude if you look like put it
this way if Hugh Jackman shaved his head
bald when he was shooting Wolverine
right I'm just saying would have had hot
dog sausages under there like that
[__] rodeo and Juliet dude okay okay
all right let's play this guy next one
Chris I saw you in Providence it was
amazing wife actually gave me uh the
tickets to the show and I have the and I
watched her tune in to meet you after
the show oh yeah
um when I met you about I brought up a
real hitting issue and I think we need
to talk about it a little bit more okay
and the issue is well as you know your
last name is Delia yes my last name is
demilia yeah I remember this and we have
an apostrophe between the Deep yeah I
remember it and yeah oftentimes when I'm
trying to sign up for something or book
something let's say like a flight yeah
um no apostrophe the website just does
not accept the apostrophe it drives me
natural character it's like an ampersand
that's annoying yourself 39 other times
I'm at a company and they're looking my
name up and they can't find them because
of the posture at all yeah pick one life
and usually it's because they're either
missing the apostrophe or they put a
space so right I want to raise awareness
of this
so my question is
how do we deal with this apostrophe and
how can we make this
more of a known thing
you know I'm also beginning to think
that the real conspiracy so well spoken
Theory with your uh YouTube Pages
because of the apostrophe oh cheers guys
rehearsed it 25 times before he did it
yeah dude we're going to want to go back
to that one by the way because I want to
see the beginning of that again but it's
so annoying that life doesn't have a way
there's so many names apostrophes in it
dude it's like why with the apology
Community is up in arms because why why
because it's a it's it's a it's
affecting a group that isn't put upon
enough to get together to try to change
it yeah I understand it's not oh well
then why the public because basically oh
no I get it no I get it because a
positive Community the apostrophe
Community is a community but but people
act like you know of course trans and
blacks and Asians yes I get that but the
apostropy community is [__] real but
not really because the the oppression
that we're facing is just trying to fill
out an uh uh form online but why why
isn't an apostrophe acceptable why is it
Ampersand quote 39 Dash yeah whatever
because people go like this whoever's in
charge is to go uh yeah I didn't really
get around to it yet and then and then
other guy goes like this yeah but
doesn't it seem like there's nothing to
get around to there's just make it
possible to put it in it's not a letter
though but it's a character they only
take letters they should take letters
and also the apostrophe because those
are in a lot of names yes you're right
you know what this is discriminatory on
Italian dashes are in names
they are did hyphenated names oh right
yeah do they take those
I don't know I'm assuming they do they
they obviously have a um it's against
Italians forms yeah but French people
have it too
yeah uh apostrophes yeah I know oh okay
so that guy go back to the beginning of
his video a lot of African names out can
you why take this hit before your
brothers so [__] Christmas
to do it wow dude the balls to take that
pause hey
what's up Delia Brothers dude such a mob
boss holy [__]
literally under him I got like this I
wire around his neck
dude what's his name
he's like the demilio isn't that the
same last name as the girls I don't know
yeah but that's different oh it is okay
uh all right well yeah
we need to get a group together me him
and you yeah but and this is why I'm
saying it hasn't happened because there
are too many people like me who are like
ah I can't get too up in arms about it
I'm not passionate enough about this if
it was like we were being persecuted in
a real way then it would be different as
some girls those are the groups that
create actual change nobody's getting
beat up you know yeah there's no racial
slur like yeah you high commas no yeah
no there's [__] for Italians yeah but
that's not yeah they're there's form
filler like online people what you said
a high commas
you up for Decker commas yeah yeah uh I
think we're just destined to have issues
with this until until someone starts
beating the [__] out of us and then we
use that because of that com you know
race this [__] kicked out of you because
of that yeah that's what I'm saying okay
you [__] you know what I mean yeah I
do top level
periods with wow you know jumping from
the Top Line you know in a wrestling
ring all right all right we're done with
that
hey Mountain Chris hope you're doing
well love the show my question is about
my husband so he loves video games and
he plays maybe like five hours a day
divorce him
um I've always tried to support him in
his Hobby and not try to like take it
away because it's just what he loves to
do but the problem is he doesn't really
have other healthy lifestyle habits
divorce hobbies and I really value like
having a productive healthy lifestyle so
it's a divorcement like spend so much
time playing video games
um so I'm just curious at what point do
you think video games like get to be too
much an addiction
um and just how would you deal with a
situation like this thanks is he making
the yaper or not I would divorce him if
he's making the Yap or good if he's not
making the game okay and also if he's
being being with you if the video game
playing is getting in the way of your
relationship or the yaper you got to
really have a talk in any way though not
like if it's made him if it counts if
it's like making them late to some stuff
that counts yeah of course yeah it has
to be more his mood later on
yeah if you can like talk to him while
he's doing if it's if he's just like
around the house for five hours and it's
like me did you say five hours a day
yeah yeah so
listen to me you're young enough to get
out your days are 19 hours
your days are 19 hours because of this
[__] video game playing
[__] oh no no no no no I don't agree
okay I don't know okay first of all we
don't have all the context okay give us
enough no because what if his job is
being on Twitch and making money playing
video games obviously she would have
said that oh and people aren't nuts okay
but you could be absolutely up to lunch
but why make that leap everyone calling
in could be absolutely out to lunch dude
if if your me time is five hours a day
it's probably too much okay if you're in
a relationship if you're trying to have
a family I know she looks young you know
what I mean yeah but like you know
he might be like it's not five hours a
day you know sometimes I don't play
Saturday Sunday with every other caller
let's assume guys take it at face value
okay
that is the truth
what would you what what do you advise
to her I think five oh okay if we're
just taking it face foul I think five
hours a day is is too much it's a lot
yeah it is too much yeah yeah uh so
she's saying what she what could she do
what should she do you're saying if it's
if it remains to be five look you have
to decide if you want to live with that
or not because it's not going to change
others do I think it's an addiction I do
think it's probably an addiction if he's
just you know doing it five hours
because also video games they're they're
geared towards making you stay it's like
Vegas with no box exactly you know so
it's like you're trying to you're you're
it's not gonna let him leave he has to
choose okay
um I'm I'm done with this I Gotta Throw
My PS5 out
um but here's the thing ask him as nice
or as however you want yeah
can you do it a little less right about
half of that she probably has already
right but if she hasn't started there
start there but if like if you really
want it to change
you should seriously consider that he's
not going to yeah because assuming you
have asked for three hours instead of
five or something like that and he
hasn't given it to you why would we
imagine that change is around the corner
he he doesn't appear to be giving you
any reason to think he's going to change
and also you gotta if you say like look
you know I think this is because the the
definition of addiction is if it's
getting into the way of your of your
other of your of your life you know what
I mean so if you're willing to be like
yo this upsets me and if you're gonna be
playing video games five hours a day for
the rest of our lives I don't know if I
want to be in this relationship then
that's what it is and it's affecting his
life and you know he probably will
because he's a guy I would have gotten
defensive and been like what the [__]
you know like oh wow it's what I like
having fun why are you trying to control
me you know I make money for this for
the for us it's okay like whatever it is
it's just you know I don't know man like
yeah I
I mean at first I was joking about
divorcing but like
if that really you got to be real with
yourself because you can't assume he's
gonna change you got to decide if it's
good if that's workable for you because
what if he doesn't change moreover what
if he gets worse five hours a day I've
heard people 10 hours a day 15 hours a
day I've heard people they don't leave
their bedroom but we used to play in our
20s we used to play a lot and we don't
why we just don't play anymore
I never
would spend five hours a day by myself
playing video games well you know there
would be the odd idea that I was playing
with his friends online that's the
difference now though
everyone really seemed to be have it
have a thing for defending this guy and
that's pissing me off I just I like to
look at the whole picture and you don't
you know if we could but we can't so we
got to take our word for it okay all
right all right
no yeah it's a tough thing man bring it
up and say yo yo it has to change like
yeah so be real about it yeah be very
real about it be like look this this is
not okay we're a young couple we got to
be out in the world doing things getting
to know each other better
hidden Mr winky up every day every day
or at least every other day hitting Mr
winky up waking up Mr winky dude
starring Richard Dreyfuss dude you are
too young yeah to be okay with just a
19-hour day every day of your life with
your husband well okay how young she
looks mad young she looked like she was
like 20. during their 20s yeah
or she is okay all right yeah
is my beard painted on yes
what
so you guys can't even say anything
about it but here's my question my
brother plays video games a lot
and this one specific video game he's
always like
I gotta work
and I'm I'm like work
it's your day off
he goes no I gotta grind
Destiny that's the name of the game huh
and I'm like
you know what I mean so what's like a
what's like a funny thing that I could
say a funny clap back that I could say
to him
in those moments because it makes me
just want to pull my hair out of my head
and be like how about you go to the gym
but you know that's just me because I'm
trying to project on others what do you
guys think he's saying that his brother
says I gotta go to work and then he says
yeah and then he says no I know I know I
don't actually have to work I gotta
grind on Destiny I think the only thing
to say is oh okay well if you keep that
up your destiny is to be a [__] loser
that's
it you're welcome bye bye bye I mean
that's bye-bye I knew that wasn't going
to be the end of it bye bye now bye bye
shave bye bye well he him shave bye bye
cut your hair bye-bye I know his brother
has the same hair no I'm saying about
him yeah yeah
I don't know that's uh they don't ever
say something is something it's not
don't say you have to work wait I gotta
do you gotta go to work
why he even included that part of the
story to us like what what what bearing
does that have on the point he's trying
to convey to us
none
do it again do the video again and and
don't do that part
so what we'll do what part then just the
part about what are you doing today I'm
gonna go oh yeah yeah like what because
his brother's like Yo dude I'll see you
in a little bit gotta go to work
only knows the songs from like the first
November
Yeah by now right there is one actually
I know what is it
who knows but what is it all right okay
cool yeah that that yeah all right all
right next
hey Chris and Matt I'm a huge fan Chris
I'll see you in Minneapolis
this little guy
asked me if I'd take him in I've had
them for about a week and I fall in love
with them oh
um but if I'm being truthful I just
don't know if I'm fit to be a pet owner
at this point in my life I'm a college
student and the responsibility has been
very overwhelming
um and I can't just take off like I used
to or you know
extended amount of time kind of like
having a show but the main concern is
that if you would need a medical
procedure or a surgery that I would not
be able to afford it and obviously I
want to give him the best quality of
life possible
um I love him very much but there's just
been other things like my whole sleep
schedules messed up and she just got it
for a little bit but I don't know like
my boyfriend had an honest conversation
with me was like you need to really
think about this yeah I get what's going
on okay is this something that you are
willing to commit to and like do all the
things like to the best of your
abilities so anything helps thank you
are you overthinking it your boyfriend
understandably doesn't want you to keep
it but it's new
give it more time yeah because I'll tell
you what about a cat it's gonna as you
as my brother just put it it's kind of
like just having another shelf in your
house yeah it does nothing it needs
nothing yeah it takes care of itself it
takes pride in doing so yeah it doesn't
really need anything from you it just
needs you to leave food for it yes when
you go away and take the [__] out of its
box my buddy said he had a cat I go over
his house how I'm like does he I never
see it exactly yeah where is it you've
got a cow where is it it's nothing like
nothing like owning any other no no no
and I also also her boyfriend your
boyfriend sounds like a bit of a [__]
dude his boyfriend's just he's trying to
make keep his life convenient the cat
probably comes up on the bed when he's
trying to move yeah
with his Mr Winky and you know it's an
inconvenience for him but who cares
having a pet is the greatest thing you
can do as a young person I truly believe
that because it's a it's a good Bridge
it's a good bridge to the responsibility
that is required of an adult and there's
no better time to learn that in college
she said she's in school right yeah I
don't think I think you're jumping the
gun here you're also worried about
things that aren't necessarily going to
happen like a medical procedure yeah
also you can get animal insurance it's
mad cheap and it covers a lot of drastic
things that animals need it's like 12 a
month or something oh totally worth it
if you're worried about that
um yeah and uh
I don't know I I think that uh
yeah I I think just roll with it a
little longer yeah just give yourself
another month like she said it's been a
week I think
hold the cat keep the cat
yeah keep the cat no
keep the [__] no
pussycat he's saying so I need to bleep
it out yeah well obviously um well not
obviously to the you know the algorithm
yeah okay who's algorithm no but yeah
that's the end of the show yeah that's
horrible uh but I will see you in
Minneapolis April 1st thank you very
much for coming uh hopefully you're
bringing your boyfriend and not your cat
um but yes you go to chrisley.com for
tickets Milwaukee Minneapolis Austin
Midland uh uh uh Ohio and a bunch of
different places you if you have a
question go to watch lifeline.com click
this description link below and if you
want a one-on-one with your boy pimpin
pimpin Bout It Bout It Baby Baby
matalia you go to matalia.com book a
one-on-one session we go real deep on
whatever your problem is uh what else
that's it hey oh
like And subscribe dude like And
subscribe
thanks guys yeah
[Music]